dr amish adolja joins us now he's a
senior scholar at the johns hopkins
center for health security at the
bloomberg school of public health doctor
good morning you're in pittsburgh you've
been outspoken
in your belief that the way the j j
vaccine was
paused was a mistake you say it will
come back but it will come back damaged
can you elaborate on that
and talk about what you believe happens
next
so what i think is going to happen is
that the johnson johnson vaccine in the
minds of the public is going to
be relegated to a second tier people
think it's going to be a second best
vaccine
and they're going to be much more likely
to get the fires or modern and want to
try to steer away from the johnson
johnson because they're going to
remember the headlines they're going to
remember
this was the last in a series of
negative headlines about the johnson
johnson vaccine including
earlier headlines about people
misinterpreting its efficacy saying it
wasn't as good
and i think that's going to be damaging
because we have so much vaccine
hesitancy
in this country too much really than we
can really tolerate with a
virus this contagious anything that
contributes to vaccine hesitancy and the
anti-vaccine movement is already seizing
upon what happened with johnson johnson
is going to make it much tougher to
vaccinate the population across that
herd immunity threshold
you mentioned that 15 dropped by that
survey
in in the belief of the safety of of
that johnson and johnson
vaccine have you seen that firsthand
the day that this pause happened i had
two of my friends who were scheduled for
johnson johnson vaccines called me
and asked me what they should do because
they had read that and and the states
hadn't started to pause yet it was just
a federal pause at that point
and i actually told them go there
hopefully they're still going to give
you that vaccine but it's clearly
something
that's that's in people's minds it's all
over the all over the news and i think
this is something that's going to be
very challenging to overcome we're going
to have to be proactive we're going to
have to show the data we're going to
have to be very transparent
and i think talk about the rarity of
this side effect
and the overall risk benefit ratio of
this of this vaccine because
this vaccine is something that can
really help us with a virus that's
killing at a high rate right now that is
spreading still tens of thousands of
cases across the united states every day
so all the tools that we have are going
to look favorably
when you do a risk benefit analysis
because these these are very very safe
vaccines despite this small number of
cases that might be linked to the
johnson johnson vaccine
you're talking about the perception that
people may have of it tom and his piece
mentioned that cdc panel that is set to
meet what do you expect them to do
i suspect that pause is going to be
lifted you might see some restrictions
because
what we've seen in these six or seven
cases that have been linked is that
they're largely in
the group of a group of women between
the ages of 18 and 48 so this is
something we could try and
carve out and say in those individuals
that that seem to be at higher risk for
this rare complication
maybe the pfizer and modern vaccine
should be preferred but for everybody
else
especially older people who are at high
risk for severe covet 19 the johnson
johnson vaccine is a great option this
is what happened with
astrazeneca vaccine in europe and they
still got vaccine hesitancy but i think
that's likely the path
we're going to go i think it would have
been better to do all of this without
the pause
and really just blanket the public with
information about this
talk to health care providers about this
rare complication and how to recognize
diagnose and treat it
without this kind of blanket pause which
i think is going to have cascading
negative impact
dr amishadelja wishing great insight for
us thank you dr adulja